Film Courage: What is The Nutshell Technique?
Jill Chamberlain, Script Consultant/Author/Writer:
The Nutshell Technique is a method that I
created for my students and clients to address
this chronic problem I see that 99% of writers
fail to tell a story.
That instead the 99% situation.
All I did is I drew up 8 essential elements
required to successfully tell a story, created
this schematic (one-page schematic) and these
are not beats in time, these are elements
that are connected that’s what makes it
different.
This isn’t a strictly linear structure.
If you look at the form (and folks can download
my form from my website Jill Chamberlain (dot)
com) the key is the connect...see all of these
little arrows and things explain the connection
between the boxes and that’s what makes
it different.
I’m getting at the glue that is required
to tell a story, that is required to make
sure that it’s not episodic.
A story is not isolated events, there’s
a connection between them and this gets you
visually (to see) and identify first of all
what are those elements?
Do you have those 8 elements in your story.
Then are they working together in conjunction.
They need to work together.
It’s about making choices actually.
It’s about finding out what you are married
to because it forces you to get out of your
head and on this piece of paper and it’s
not a lot of homework.
It’s not like I’m asking you to write
a long beat sheet (multi-page beat sheet)
to explain.
It’s pretty brief (one page)…let’s see
if I can identify these 8 elements first of
all.
If you can’t you want to see visually how
they’re working together and if they’re
not working you can see it right on the form.
So it’s a way of finding out what am I married
to?
I really love this premise about a guy who
wakes up and it’s the same day all over
again.
But it’s not working with this flaw that
I identified that he is naive.
That flaw doesn’t work with this.
Which one do you want to change?
Do you want to change the flaw or change the
great premise?
I’d probably stick with the great premise
right?
But then I’d have to think what would be
the right character to put in that circumstance
where they wake up and it’s the same day
again?
Somebody who is naive, that wouldn’t really
work.
That’s not a really good test for them.
What about somebody who is really self-centric?
Right?
Now you can see the form “okay that works
much better.”
This is going to be a much better test than
somebody who is self-centered and self-centric
if they are repeating the same day again and
again.
It’s going to get really boring right?
It’s going to force them to start trying
different things and maybe finally change
and find something better in themselves and
they realize that life isn’t really worth
living if you’re just living it for yourself
everyday, right?
So it’s going to take him all of that time
to figure out in this journey and this test
you put him on in suddenly being caught in
a universe where he’s waking up and it’s
the same day again to finally face this flaw
deep down in himself and to find a way to
change and that’s how he breaks from the
cycle.
Film Courage: And also play off of someone
who is more naive and who also has sort of
a broader view of the world.
Jill: Right, as a contrast to that character.
So it’s a way of just isolating these elements
really simply.
It’s very simple method really.
Very simply you can see what’s working and
what’s not working right there on a piece
of paper.
It’s just a matter of kind of small adjustments
very often can make a huge difference between
a huge story first of all not working (being
a situation and not feeling satisfying and
one that is satisfying.
It helps you find that unexpected and surprising
ending and satisfying way of doing things
that you’re probably not going to find otherwise
if you’re just following a beat sheet method
or if you’re just keep with a situation.